so let's say you got to describe this
show music how do you describe what is
this an amalgamation of describe the
show
oh so conversation we just had so was
that one Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles is
what we come up with usually yeah a
little bit is a blender and you need to
just like dump it yeah the Warriors
that's the nice thing about that is that
you're gonna bring in all those other
all those disparate fandoms and go oh
yeah like we get it look when they watch
it but yeah sure are you guys there did
we say Goonies we said because we have
in different episodes you have moments
really like oh my gosh that's like
whatever
maybe Care Bears I don't know but the
point is is like it's cool because
you're right there's there's so many
different opportunities for other
fandoms to kind of watch the show and
really relate to it in ways that maybe
if you're stuck in one universe you
don't again yeah in a lot of ways it's
kind of also its own thing - yeah you
really can not same in the way you can
describe other shows it's also very much
so Outer Banks its own you know yeah
it's a rip-roaring good time the setting
in itself is like a major character I'm
gonna say yeah in this job you're
there's like boat chase this yeah
there's a there's like digging and
diving for secrets like all sorts of
stuff I'm watching the show I'm seeing
you guys out in the water and I'm going
like mosquitoes we were in the middle of
a take and I got a mosquito bite right
on the mill but more heads I was like
make up
yeah it was like mosquitoes were
obsessed with him yeah they would get
bit and next thing you know his face
would just swell up like his whole cheek
and he died and the enough for spies to
horseman there was one there was one
thing they were driving I lived got bit
by a horse by every single take every
time and like and of course fly bite is
like if like if like a bee was like more
mad at you it's just like it's like
somebody story here's four for young
aspiring actresses like glamour well I
hope Glen yeah that's what this is yeah
it's super glamorous yeah I thought it
was super glamorous and then you get to
set in the morning they put on sunscreen
and chopstick and they're like we'll see
you tomorrow like the one shoulder it's
not like hair coming and touching and
it's not if you think stranger things
has good hair like look you look like
real gross gross kids oh yeah so much
yeah dirt was unanimous
so it's like reality really yeah so what
the like the big storm of one of the big
stories about this I guess is a treasure
hunt right like if you guys came across
something worth hundreds of millions of
dollars like what are you doing with
that our house out I was like if I had
you found it kind of what happens in the
show so when I would have to say you
know I'd go on a fat vacation I wouldn't
tell anybody
nice I tell my family but I wouldn't
tell anybody else they all know and all
the Canada knows now so all over socks
you know remember I would tell is you
like 20 bucks to get a big bang payable
which interesting